Fahrt zu einer kriegstrophäe die Galaxy
Leader im Besitz eines israelischen
Unternehmers nun gekarp im Roten Meer
gerade einem westlichen Fernsehteam
wollen die Kriegsherren ihre Beute
vorführen als eine Art
[Musik]
Exempel gott ist groß Tod Amerika Tod
Israel verflucht sein die Juden siegt
dem Islam rufen ä nicht ohne ein wir
erobern Jerusalem
hinzuzufügen ein Teil der Crew soll an
Bord sein erfahre ich in Geiselhaft
keine Sorge sagen die hthis es gehe der
Crew gut sie sein versorgt
überall an Deck die Gesichter der
Getöteten Kämpfer viele noch Teenager
wollen sie nur einen Waffenstillstand in
Gaza erzwingen wie sie sagen oder ist
das was wir sehen der neue heilige Krieg
der
huis unsere Krieger haben die Jemeniten
stolz gemacht sie haben die USA Israel
Deutschland und Großbritannien mit Füßen
getreten wir wollen herausfinden wie die
huthis das Land verändert haben wer sich
zwischen den bürgerkriegsfronten im
Jemen bewegen will braucht Zeit und
Nerven statt Straßen finden sich fast
nur noch Schotterpisten und gefährliche
Bergpässe zwischen Nord und Süd zwischen
hthi Gebiet und international
anerkannter
[Musik]
Regierung die Hauptstadt San 2014 von
den his
erobert erwarten Sie hier einen
polizeistat so abgeschottet wie
Nordkorea hatten exiljeminiten uns
vorgewarnt die Bilder getöteter
militionäre trägen das Stadtbild
die Angst der Menschen mit uns zu spre
vor unseren Begleitern von der
Staatssicherheit ist
groß Revolutionsführer Abdel hat wie
sein Vater eine Weile im Iran gelebt die
Herrschaft der schiitischen mullas ist
sein
vorbildti familienan sieht sich als von
Gott auserwählt und dem Volk
überlegeniner anblichen Abstammung v
propeten
ein allwöchentliches machitual der his
darf ich nur mit schwarzem Umhang und
Kopftuch teilnehmen sagt man
mir mehr als eine Million Männer treffen
sich um ihren Hass auf den Westen auf
Israel und auf die Juden freien Lauf zu
lassen Frauen sind hier tabu ich bin
eine Ausnahme fast jeder trägt eine
Waffe trotzdem wird jeder erstem
durchsucht Krieg bis zum Weltkrieg so
lautet einer der sprechköre der
Machtanspruch der his erstreckt sich auf
den ganzen Jemen und darüber hinaus sie
wollen ein globales islamisches Kalifat
die Saudis die die Regierung Jemens
unterstützen werden als Ungläubige
gebranntmarkt genauso wie die USA schon
die Kleinsten werden mit dieser
Ideologie
indoktriniert Krieg gegen die USA für
die his wäre das eine Ehre sagt einer
ihrer Minister
unser Führer hat der EU und Deutschland
geraten sich hier nicht
einzumischen wir hoffen Deutschland wird
sich den USA nicht anschließen sonst
eskalieren wir und weiten unsere Ziele
aus auf andere Länder
über Dutzende Checkpoints fahren wir auf
die andere Seite der
bürgerkriegsfront um herauszubekommen
wie die Menschen dort unter dem Krieg
mit den H leidenen wir stad vom
jahrelangen häusekampf
gezeichnet der Nordteil der Stadt ist
von his besetzt die Blockade bedeutet
dass Familien voneinander getrennt sind
dass an der Front geschossen wird dass
die his Hunger und Durst als Waffe
einsetzen damit die Menschen sich
endlich
ergeben die Familie von faat abd lebt
nahe der
Frontlinie in einem Haus ohne
Fensterscheiben ohne Strom ohne fließend
Wasser ein Leben ohne
würde es ist alles wegen der his ohne
sie wäre es nie so weit gekommen die his
haben uns aus unseren Häusern vertrieben
die Menschen hatten ein gutes Leben aber
die his zerstörten die
Häuser zahllose Menschen in TS sind
verstümmelt Scharfschützen zielten immer
noch auf Zivilisten erzählen sie auch
auf FA
Nachbarn verschonen weder Frauen noch
Kinder noch alte noch junge sie schießen
auf jeden sie werden vom Iran
unterstützt ihr Ziel ist ganz einfach
unseren Jemen zu
zerstören mit neu aufgehäuften
Schuttbergen auf den Straßen versucht es
Militär Zivilisten irgendwie aus der
Schusslinie zu
nehmen Leben in das butet nicht zu
wissen ob die Kinder lebend von der
Schule
zurückkehren es bedeutet Fingerkuppen zu
verlieren weil sie Minen angefasst haben
die Zahl der Opfer steigt gerade
sprunghaft erzählen die Mütter die
meisten Minen hier haben die his
hinterlassen die his haben Minen und
explosives Zeug in Getränkekartons
gesteckt als einer unserer Nachbarn so
einen Karton zertreten hat er dachte er
könne damit spielen explodierte das ganz
und er wurde
getötet Minen Aufklärungsunterricht in
einer Schule ins viele Schüler
unterstützen ihre Familien mit dem
Sammeln und Verkaufen von Metall hier
lernen sie wie gefährlich das sein
kann dieser Krieg hat alle voneinander
getrennt ich will dass die Leute in ihre
Häuser zurückkehren sich miteinander
vereinen dass sie wie Brüder werden so
wie es vor dem Krieg war
der neue Krieg der huis hat den Jemen
aus der Vergessenheit zurückgeholt aber
das Leid das die huis über die Menschen
gebracht haben bleibt der Welt
unbekannt